I'm joined today by dr. Leonard Cruz
who's editor-in-chief of Chiron
publications and is also co-founder of
the Asheville young Center
he's a cuban-american writer editor and
psychiatrist as well as co-author of
dsm-5 insanely simplified we are talking
today about the book a clear and present
danger narcissism in the era in the era
of Donald Trump a very very relevant
issue dr. Cruz so let's start at the
very beginning sometimes people get
confused between many of these terms
sociopathy psychopathy narcissism etc
what are we talking about when we're
talking about narcissism
well thanks first for having us on
narcissism is everything that spans from
the normal realm of the healthy aspects
that allow us to become invested in
ourselves
and develop a normal healthy sense of
self all the way into the realm of the
pathologic which at its worst becomes
what clinically is referred to as
narcissistic personality disorder and
that being a condition in which the
features of the narcissism become fairly
fixed immutable they imposed themselves
in all sorts of dimensions of an
individual's life is narcissism or
narcissistic personality disorder is
this something that is that the
consensus is this is something that is a
result of environment or is it something
that is a result of genetics or heredity
there's no real consensus on the matter
I think what you could fairly say is
that under certain circumstances if a
person's wounds in childhood and in
their developmental years are of a
particular nature one of the
compensatory reactions might be the
development of narcissistic inflation so
whether that's also influenced by
genetics hard to say but but more often
than not I think the opinion would be
that it's the environment that shapes
the individual and that narcissism
and in some respects is kind of a
compensation that ends up becoming a
rather huge Distortion like I said
earlier that they would remember
narcissism by itself in terms of
psychological jargon is part of a normal
development we all start off completely
self-absorbed and as we go through life
hopefully the presence of others in our
life become increasingly more important
and become a part of our weave so with
regard to Donald Trump the
president-elect now talked to us about
the analysis and evaluation that you did
in relation to narcissism and sort of
what what you believe to be the case the
connection between narcissism and Donald
Trump you know there is a lot of
discussion on the subject of how do we
explain the phenomenon of this
individual who's risen to the presidency
and also maybe some equal amount of
interest in how do we explain the
response that he evoked in the
electorate and I want a kind of footnote
although it's throughout the book I
think it's important to even footnote
here on the program that it isn't really
our intention or expectation that we're
diagnosing somebody from afar in fact
the American Psychiatric Association
because of an incident back in the
goldwater period promulgated a rule that
for all intent purposes discourages and
all but forbids the diagnosis of
somebody you've never laid eyes on and
had an interaction with okay Gladys song
if you didn't mention it I was going to
next so I'm glad we got that out of the
way yeah yes but but you know that aside
I think it's not unreasonable to suppose
that everybody is trying to apply and
figure out how do we explain this
individual his behavior the
characteristics that we see so with that
in mind I don't know that there's a
consensus that this individual has a
narcissistic personality disorder I
think there's been an appropriate amount
of reserve from clinicians not wanting
to breach that divide and make the
diagnosis but I think even by Donald
Trump's own admission he was quoted in
in a book in response to a book written
by an analyst from Washington who
actually described him it was describing
the productive narcissist and
Trump by his own words kind of signs the
label to himself that he thinks he's a
productive narcissist so that combined
with a whole lot of other things that
have issued forth from Donald Trump
I think certainly raised the specter of
that phenomenon and then of course the
question is I think is just as equally
interesting is what kind of response
does an individual with narcissistic
personality traits evoke in others and
in this case how did he do that in a
very large broad collective capacity yes
so let's address that I mean what
element when when we think of the ways
in which Donald Trump appeal to
different elements of the electorate
that ultimately saw him winning the
electoral vote by as a result of 80,000
votes in three particular states what
was it about Donald Trump's public
persona that may have appealed to others
in a way that's relevant to the
narcissism analysis you know one of the
things that I found perhaps the most
compelling was during the lead-up to his
nomination when we were watching the all
17 candidates on stage at once there was
this one of the debates I don't remember
which one in particular where it was
held but I remember distinctly it was
the one in which he began name-calling
various different candidates he called
marco rubio little Marco and Donald
Trump he ridicule
I mean a Jeb Bush he ridiculed for his
kind of energic a pathetic kind of
weakened state flow and um yeah low
energy low energy Jeb right or lyin Ted
he had a moniker for every your the
thing I was really struck by on that one
David was that everybody I've known and
all men that I've known have in one way
or another encountered a bully you know
when you were growing up either were the
subject of a bully you were perhaps the
bully yourself or you were witness to
the bully and not sure exactly how to
engage and I I watched that scene and I
was powerfully struck by the fact that
there was this presidential candidate
who was basically tapping into something
that is probably very primal and present
in all of us that we
all been treated by the bully in Mon
fashion or another whether we had to
align with them to avoid our own skin
getting scorched or whether we were the
bullet II and you know it was
interesting to watch these very
competent individuals not standing their
ground to the bully same way you might
have watched on a playground so I
mentioned that as a footnote because in
trying to figure out what what did he
tap into collectively some people at
least in the book argued and I think
there's some merit to this that there
were there has been over the last
depending on when you want to mark the
starting point a sort of loss of esteem
loss of power loss of a sense of
privilege you know we've heard a lot of
that bantered around whether it was just
white uneducated males we saw clearly
that he tapped into something beyond
that that but there was a collective
sense that we as a nation we as as
people perhaps who enjoyed some
privilege have seen that receding and I
think he combined that with this
skillful ability to promise things that
most of us understood were improbable or
impossible to achieve but somehow you
felt like your own wounds have been
healed so I think there's something
about that fact that all of us have felt
wounded at some level whether it was
personally on a playground or
collectively when you see the Twin
Towers go down where you see our defeat
in Vietnam and he managed to tap into
that and and then I think like many
people who have demagogue equalities do
he had an amazing ability to promise the
moon which were already seeing him
backing up from when we think about
these narcissistic tendencies or
personality traits in the context of
being president and making decisions
that a president makes what's your sense
of of what the interplay there might be
in what way might these tendencies
impact how someone is as president of
the United States my biggest fear and I
think one of the purposes that we had
behind writing the book and compiling
the different perspectives that the
authors and
had was this was more than just
illuminating the field about Donald
Trump the person this was also hoping to
shed some light on the very phenomenon
of narcissism whether you encounter it
in your workplace because you're working
for somebody who's got narcissistic
traits whether you're married to
somebody who's narcissistic or whether
you're being led as a nation by somebody
so that was really one of the underlying
intents and my biggest concern with that
idea in mind is for the narcissistic
individual there's a very blurred
boundary between the sense of the other
and themselves I mean to a certain
extent the people who have narcissistic
personality disorder
you could almost understand it as they
treat individuals and others around them
in the same way you would an inanimate
object if you know if I have a pen that
is a precious and valued pen and it
suddenly runs out of ink I really have
no use for it anymore and I treat it
with kind of disdain and disregard and I
think one of the dangers that I think
awaits people who have narcissistic
traits when they're imbued with a
political power is that provided
somebody as as something that they need
they may very well esteem them they may
very well over esteem them the moment
that ceases to be the case they may cast
them aside
treat them dismissively and even worse
treat them scornfully and I think we've
seen some evidence that when when
president elect Trump deals with the
media it really depends in large measure
how he's feeling at that moment in time
as to whether he regains the media or he
scorns them mostly it's been scornful
yeah and I think the other example would
be people that are friendly to Trump are
just the best people in the world and
people who maybe once were friendly but
are no longer are really just
fundamentally terrible people and we've
seen that happen too time and again in
terms of the people Trump associates
with very very interesting again the
book is a clear and present danger
narcissism in the era of Donald Trump
we've been speaking with the book's
co-author dr. Leonard Cruz
thanks so much for talking to us about
this oh you're very welcome - thank you
for having us on